last year at this time the 49ers were
getting ready to host the vikings in the
nfc divisional round there was thought
that defensive coordinator robert sala
would get a job somewhere he did not in
the last cycle
he may in this cycle he has finished
his second interview with the jets today
earlier
on pft live chris sims suggested that
salah is the favorite to get the job
with the new york jets there have been
other reports suggesting that saleh
is number one on the list but saul is
also talking to the eagles now this may
just be leverage
aimed at getting the best possible
contract this may just be a courtesy
whatever it may be it's not done until
it's done we learned that three years
ago with josh mcdaniels but it seems to
be moving shireen in the direction
of robert sala having an opportunity to
become the next head coach of the new
york jets
yeah it sounds like they're bringing
other guys in mike for second interviews
for in-person interviews at their
team facility so it's not a done deal
yet
obviously but it does seem like he is
the leader in the clubhouse so to speak
but
you know if they really wanted a mic
that badly they wouldn't let him let
leave the building either and go to
philadelphia where now the eagles
i guess technically wouldn't have it
well i guess they would they could
sign him and not let him get back to the
jets if they
uh want to do that so you know it's kind
of the thing with in free agency once
you let him walk out the building he's
talking to other people and he's
obviously had a lot of interviews so
maybe he likes somebody better after he
leaves you you never know
it's the matt rule dynamic they had him
in carolina last year he was due to meet
with the giants and they got him
signed before he ever left now along the
way a phone call was made to the giants
with an indication of what the panthers
were going to pay matt rule
and the giants politely hung up the
phone they're not going to pay that
amount of money
that's going to be the other interesting
dynamic what coaches make
first year given what happened last year
with david tepper the panthers
owner resetting the market and blowing
open the curve
because the owners don't want to overpay
for coaches and they
found a way to keep coaching salary
growth
down relative to player salary growth
relative to revenue
growth and this year could be an
opportunity to reel things back in by
pointing to the losses from the pandemic
sorry we can't pay 9 million we can't
pay 8 million we'll pay what we pay and
we're all
coincidentally we're all offering the
same amount pick a job we're all paying
the same
there is a little bit of collusion that
happens but with no union
for the coaches and no coach willing to
trade his career for the ability to file
a lawsuit
nobody's ever going to do anything about
it
yeah mike and they're going to pay what
they pay i think it's going to be like
that in free agency for some of these
veteran players too i don't think they
realize what's going to happen
when you come into free agency in march
and april a lot of them are expecting to
get big contracts i don't know that
those are going to be there this is just
a different year and it's
probably not the best year to be a coach
or be a player free agent
looking for a job because the numbers
probably will come down some based on
ticket revenue not being there for these
owners
and they're going to look to cut costs
any possible way they can mike
point that i think we made earlier today
on pft live and something i've been
meaning to write about
the idea that we talked about this
yesterday the coaches so rarely just
choose to become free agents it was with
john schneider the general manager had a
year left on his contract could have
said hey i'm not signing your contract
extension i'll just play out my contract
or work out my contract as the case may
be
and become a free agent i'm still
surprised coaches don't do that but
they're afraid
that they're gonna step into a situation
where
there's no job for them anywhere else
and also to the extent that there's any
true collusion happening among the
coaching
hires maybe if a guy drives too hard of
a bargain
no one else will want him just to
courtesy to the team
that otherwise would see him walking
away my concern about robert saul of the
jets
is similar to a broader concern that
i've stated this offseason
hiring a defensive coach can create a
potential problem for you because if
your team does well your offensive
coordinator is going to get hired by the
another team as a head coach i wrote
about that today on twitter and
reasoning with twitter is like trying to
teach your dog to fly an airplane it
just doesn't happen especially if you
don't know how to fly an airplane
yourself
but but i think that is a legitimate
concern if you bring in
an offensive coordinator who finally
gets the most out of sam
darnold and the jets go 11 and 5 within
the next couple of years
that offensive coordinator becomes a
coaching candidate and you may lose him
and then you got to hire
another guy and hope that it works look
at the revolving door mike zimmer's had
in minnesota for reasons
both attributable to success of the team
and mike zimmer isn't the easiest guy in
the world to work with apparently but
if you have an offensive coach i think
it's
easier to survive the turnover that
naturally happens as a result of success
like andy reid in kansas city you lose
your offensive coordinator that's all
right i'm the offensive coordinator you
lose your defensive coordinator well
that doesn't happen very often for a
great offensive coach dennis allen's
still stuck in new orleans and you never
even hear his name mentioned
for head coaching jobs which is still
strange so i i just would
would err on the side of an offensive
coach especially when the quarterback
position
needs so much work and you need someone
to connect with sam darnold or whoever
you draft with the second overall pick
that's my that's my concern i know jets
fans are so desperate just to be
relevant they don't care
that's a good problem to have but i
still can continue to say that the only
good problem is no problem and i'd
rather not lose my offensive coordinator
so quickly if if my defensive minded
head coach turns things around
and especially if you don't have an
established quarterback
mike in the situation of sam darnold you
know it's probably a little different
in houston because they have an
established quarterback
but they need an offensive guy to come
in in in
with the jets and see if they can save
sam darnold's career see
if he is salvageable if he is a
legit franchise quarterback i don't
think anyone knows that yet
so i was curious to see i mean they've
interviewed so many people this seems
like a weird cycle to me because
they've interviewed so many people every
team has and it just seems like it's
slow the hirings are really
slow slower than they usually are but i
look at the jets
they've interviewed four offensive
coaches and six defensive coaches
uh counting salah so it's kind of
strange
that when you have a sam darnold as your
quarterback and really need to develop
him
you are looking at so many defensive
coaches and i know a lot of
owners will tell you hey we just want
the best coach but most times i'm with
you most times the
the best coach is going to be an
offensive coach because
this is an offensive game now defense
can only do so much
for you the rams defense is really
special this season
we've seen them score defensive
touchdowns i don't think any of us
are looking at them as a super bowl
contender that they're going to go and
win the super bowl
just because their defense is ranked
number one in the nfl they've got to
have more
offense if they want to do that and they
don't have enough this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports